ich denke einfach abmelden würde auf
jeden fall sehen lassen bis sie jetzt
gleich hinter der wissenschafts wirklich
immer wieder also zu schocken wird leute
jetzt bekommen sie in einem video auf
bestimmte ja was ist das setting
sebastian hier gerade ich bin bei alex
wie ins kinderzimmer eingebrochen habe
mir zeit genommen
also ich finde es eigentlich ganz meist
beschränkt da hinten da gar nicht mal
türen hat oder ich hab ich nämlich jetzt
habe ich ja aber ich finde es auch gut
oder und deutete der grund dafür dass
wir in diesem setting ist egal besitzen
ist dass wir uns entschieden haben
zusammen
rebecca mir ein bisschen zu bringen aber
richtig zu grillen förderstufe maximal
magath auf gebildet gesagt nämlich dass
alex auch gewissermaßen seine eigene
vorgeschichte mit dem wetter hat also
rebecca hat schon mehrmals seine videos
geklaut man geht davon aus man kann sich
endgültig beilegen aufschlag sachen
leben die noch genauer becker hat bei
ihnen höchstwahrscheinlich ein paar
videos geklaut aber muss mittlerweile
davon ausgehen da hast du wieder darüber
gemacht und das war eigentlich hat sich
nur abgefragt ist mein name hatte weil
bei ihr zensiert ist das für dich
entscheidest du weißt ja weil das finde
ich dann schon zu dreist man kann ich
finde video kann man jetzt gar nicht mal
so schlimm
am besten ist ja dann immer wenn man
dann auch noch sagt dass man das da
gesehen hat
bei an formaten muss ich auch sagen dass
ich selber nicht mal meinem format ist
der erste das in deutschland gemacht
aber nicht generell nur so ein anderes
format das war wirklich von mir soll ihr
auch eins zu eins übernommen
das ist fakt damals schon apa ich darf
sollte man kann mit recht sagen dass
rebecca von der videos geklaut hat und
dann hast du doch mal wieder gemacht das
habe ich auch gesehen passiert als
kontext noch sehen wollte diese
vectoring klau geschichte habe ich und
in der beschreibung von links zweiter
link der erste link in der beschreibung
führt zu dem video was wir bei alex
gemacht haben die heimlich zusammen
jeweils auf einem kanal von uns ein
video von rebecca ding auseinander
genommen das für alex kann alles schon
gedreht das thema das vermeiden und ich
würde sagen leute wir haben hier eine
hochwertige produktionen unter wasser
als echte ariel meerjungfrau für ein
vogel essen und schlafen ja sonst jedoch
absolut interessant das hört sich dann
und ich glaube die war wirklich 40 schon
im pulverfass
vielleicht kurz ergänzen kann wir haben
wir uns ja darauf geeinigt wenn das
nächste mal irgendwas verrücktes bei
rebecca geschieht reagiert zusammen das
meer und unserer meinung nach diese
beiden videos zur echten meerjungfrau
werden unter wasser als echte meldung
vor für einen tag im pool essen
schwimmen schlafen sind verrückt genug
ja also ich hab ein bisschen vollkontakt
gab dann haben sie den zeitpunkt
abgewartet zudem wir zuschlagen
übertragen und ja jetzt wettringer ist
keine ahnung mental irgendwie komplett
abgedrückt und denke es ist eine
meerjungfrau ist für alex bringt erste
liga beschreibung leute und die stadt
jetzt rein in battle for video 2 jetzt
komm ich wollte unbedingt wollen
kommentiert aber leider nicht angezeigt
könnte es daran liegen dass er kann ich
will dass leute schreiben dass das die
videos findet deswegen der name zensiert
ist ich glaube das hat andere gründe
ich glaube dass sich aber zu sehr auf
neueste schon wieder befreundet ich
wusste wir sind zwölf sekunden videos
kommt schon die erste werbung ja dazu
sagen und das video da zieht sie einfach
eine mail flosse an und hüpft denn
irgendwo im hotel irgendwo der türkei
oder so in den pool alle urlaub sind so
franke schon was mit der frau los und
filmt was eine million klicks 80.000
likes ja das ist es also na ja wir
können unsere kanäle löschen youtube ist
vorbei 80.000 fans schon über 80.000 und
nur 2000 displays ja also ich frage mich
wirklich so ich sehe schwarz für
deutschlands zukunft leute die
lightradio auf dem video in dem ihr
bekkering sich in der meerjungfrau
flosse anzieht und ein komplettes hotel
schockt mit ihrem verhalten 80.000 2000
komplett war ich 24 stunden lang in
dieser woche hier abhängen und alle
machen das heißt wirklich alles alles
versuchen sie jetzt sagt ok rumlaufen
wird nichts rumhüpfen wohl eher oder rum
robben auf dem boden alte die musste ich
innerhalb der 40 stunden sogar
fortbewegen krank oder ja nicht so dass
gedacht eigentlich nicht gemeint
das macht die sonst nicht wenn die
kamera aus geht es wird halt manchmal
recht
das wäre echt war heftig zu schnell
gefahren chinesisches unternehmen hätte
die einfach programmiert und würde
komplett youtube deutschland richtig es
gibt ja heutzutage schon menschenrechte
roboter hat die wirklich aussehen wie
menschen ob man das jetzt so gut
hingekriegt weiß ich nicht aber in 20
jahren wird so etwas geben ich glaube
das ist mit die wahrscheinlichste
theorie die ich für beck allerdings
verhalten jemals gehört habe
deswegen habe ich dir auch noch nie auf
einem youtuber treffen sind im standby
modus eine steckdose angeschlossen auch
was zum essen gefunden 40 schon wie eine
kleine meerjungfrau nicht wie eine große
leute
ok falls ihr es ja angeklickt hat um zu
sehen wie sie wie eine große menge
freizeit verbringt er seine verhindern
vergessen ich weiß ich als ich hab bei
weg bringen
wieso sollte ich das ist ja noch nie auf
einer persönlichen ebene ja das ist
einfach so man trotz die videos
allerdings nicht länger dazu muss man
was sagen ich kann mir vorstellen
bekkering wirkt so lost im leben das
hier wirklich so unter wasser geht zum
beispiel nicht weiß dass ich nicht
wirklich nur vier minuten leute werden
jetzt schon sehr viel gelacht als wir
wissen was sie macht sie behauptet 24
stunden eher vorzusehen natürlich hat
sie das nicht für seinen strom gemacht
hatte war halbe stunde gefilmt oder hab
ich habe es war wie das aussieht
persönliche sorge meines jobs ohne witz
wenn rebecca in ihre videos nicht fade
kannst du mir beide hände abhacken kein
problem wir sind die welt wirklich drauf
was einfach so rein
es gibt so sind die dinger noch mal
zurück warum das es winken roboter
sondern mp3-datei wo ist der anschluss
wurde das hat es zunächst mit dem fall
zu tun vielleicht ist das intro lied
kann da ja wahrscheinlich ist von der
wirtschafts wirklich immer wieder also
zu schocken wirst du denkst du dich
liebt und dann was mer mal was ich mich
frage kann man die ist ja im urlaub in
einem hotel der ist hier jetzt einen
luftballon und flamingo ihm zu machen
hat sie dort gekauft um also bei der
jetzt nicht mitgedacht a und o für
mehrere frau sein sind
überdimensionierte wirtschaft hast du
noch nie mehr in filmen sind jetzt voll
von überdimensionierten deutschland
bestimmt und sagt ja also das ist das
erste und flamingos sind befreundet die
unterwasser förmigen erkennen sind
[Applaus]
ich hoffe du warst eines morgens auf und
ich gebe dir 500 einfach wenn du dir
dieses bild für ein jahr das bett hengst
und ist jeden morgen beim aufwachen
apple expo ich glaube ich würde das ja
nicht überleben nicht für jeden morgen
aufwache
gut geschlafen wird wir trinken blau
blau wie das meer abfließen
diese gezeichnet wurde blau wie man sein
muss und wird
aber warte mal trinken mehr jugendfrei
sind wirklich wasser aus dem meer
ich war ja auch nicht merken frauen sind
da halb mensch halb fisch sondern weil
danach fragen du bist ja eine echte
menge frau du warst ja auch einen tag
unter wasser so ist der video
wahrscheinlich ja auch irgendwie
amphibische roboter
das ist was er nicht also die
meerjungfrauen die trinken erstmal also
wenn es ist ja ganz so a und o für uns
wasser riesenrutsche davon leben
meerjungfrau und nicht vor dieses hotel
hat so überwachungs doch direkt
irgendwie so ein typ hinschicken der
kontrolliert ob alles in ordnung ist mit
der security check sorge also brechen
ok dann kriegt eine frau mit
meerjungfrau phase durch den gang wieder
so seine brille ab heißt es in der augen
guckt also noch mal wechseln
ich kenne zu wenig kenne mich mit so
einem scheiß auseinanderzusetzen
die t shirt er hatte ja erst konnte dort
bekommt man auch bei mir ein tag als die
jungen martin und blaue schuhe machen
wir cool aber wieder macht das doch mal
24 stunden als meerjungfrau unsterblich
mache 94 stunden als krabbeldecke was in
welchen medien lebst du manche von ihren
zuschauern machen was ist mit dir du
redest die ganze zeit so als würden mehr
frauen wirklich existieren
[Musik]